[Musique]
bonsoir à tous ravis de vous retrouver
pour ce nouveau journal d'information
locale nous sommes le lundi 7 mars voici
les titres
emmanuel macron son rang dans les
yvelines ce lundi soir pour son premier
déplacement de campagne invité par karl
olive maire de poissy le candidat à sa
réélection rencontrera les yvelinois
lors d'un débat le rendez vous est donné
à 18h30 au centre de diffusion
artistique et de la ville
douze jours après le début de la guerre
en ukraine les mobilisation solidaire se
poursuivre dans les yvelines
collectivités associations encore
particuliers organisent la décollecte
objectif acheminer du matériel et des
dons sur place via des convois également
dans ce journal le témoignage d'une
yvelinoise donné deux moscou et puis la
80e édition du paris-nice et lancer la
course de cyclistes est parti de mantes
la ville ce dimanche 6 mars une première
étape remportée par le cycliste français
christophe laporte des collégiens ont pu
rencontrer à découvrir ce lundi matin
avant le départ de la deuxième étape a
offert jce
[Musique]
et je vous le disais plus d'un million
d'ukrainiens ont dû quitter le pays
depuis le déclenchement de la guerre
avec la russie pour aider la population
en exil et celles restées sur place à la
solidarité et au rendez-vous dans les
villes des yvelines à l'appel des
municipalités de nombreux habitants
répondent présent rassemblement de
soutien également aux collectes
organisées l'exemple à villepreux poissy
et montigny le bretonneux c'était est
avec grigoriy canal et bixente mais bien
senties steban et nicolas d'andré
malgré la distance la guerre est dans
toutes les têtes samedi matin une
soixantaine d'habitants s'est rassemblée
devant la mairie de villepreux un moment
de solidarité pour le peuple ukrainien
organisée par la municipalité ce qui se
passe c'est vraiment horrible quand on
va seville complètement rayé de la carte
les gens complètement parti sur les
routes moi ça me fait vraiment quelque
chose on est tous concernés et tous très
inquiet par rapport au conflit
aujourd'hui en ukraine et par rapport à
l'invasion du pouvoir politique russe on
est rassemblé pour montrer notre unité
pour montrer notre soutien et notre
solidarité à destination du peuple
ukrainien l'occasion également pour la
commune de lancer une collecte de
produits de secours et d'hygiène car
dans de nombreuses villes des yvelines
la mobilisation est au rendez vous
depuis quelques jours à l'appel de
l'association des maires de france elle
a été rapide notamment à poissy depuis
mercredi c'est plus de deux tonnes de
matériel qui on était
réceptionner qui sont ensuite
compartimentée par notre réserve
communale et citoyenne c'est un élan du
coeur à nulle autre peyrat est pareil
c'est une générosité en lettres
majuscules et et nos amis ukrainiens
valent bien c'est évidemment une
générosité qui s'opère dès le plus jeune
âge regardez les enfants y avait des
très grosses explosions ça m'a fait
beaucoup feignent moi j'avais pris une
couverture
un dentifrice et enchanteront
elle a décidé de
trier de voir ce qui pouvait servir
je montre aux enfants qui prennent
conscience de ce qui se passe et puis
ben voilà on a toutes les choses à
donner donc pas de raison de garder à
chaque fois les communes s'appuie sur
les associations présentes dans les
yvelines à montigny le bretonneux la
municipalité oeuvre avec perspective
ukrainienne présidée par unis ni
monteyne lors d'une première collecte
organisée en mairie le 4 mars 80 cartons
remplis de vêtements chauds aux sacs de
couchage et de nourriture sont partis
pour l'ukraine tous les vêtements qui
sont arrivés tous les vivres enfin
beaucoup de choses qui sont arrivées d
une heure seulement on voit que c'est
déjà plein plein plein plein de cartons
c'est la protection civile qui va s'en
charger de les acheminer sur la
frontière polonaise malheureusement elle
va pas traverser la frontière et ça va
pas être distribué directement à la
population locale mais pour les réfugiés
qui se sont de plus en plus nombreux
cela en pologne roumanie moldavie entre
les vêtements c'est plus pour des
familles qui vont arriver dans des
familles françaises une nouvelle
collecte est prévue dans la ville le 12
mars avec un rassemblement à midi devant
l'hôtel de ville l'association
perspectives ukrainienne recherche aussi
des familles d'accueil pour les
ukrainiens réfugié en france
et on vient de le voir dans ce reportage
des associations sont nombreuses à se
mobiliser pour venir en aide aux
ukrainiens par exemple il ya un élan de
solidarité fort qui se passe et on est
avec vous jean marc haas et moulin vous
êtes le directeur de l'association
chrétienne de solidarité la gerbe qui
est basée à et que vit et on est avec
vous également vont soit 20000 cas elle
pas été responsable du pôle solidarité
donc de cette association donc vous vous
êtes aussi mobilisé comme ces
associations qu'on a pu voir dans le
reportage on va revenir dans quelques
instants sur les actions vous avez mis
en place finalement bas pour cette face
à cette guerre en ukraine avant cela la
gerbe c'est une association des
d'humanitaires et qu'elles sont
globalement une émission en règle
générale de l'association une
association d aide humanitaire et en
fait on utilise ce support là pour faire
de l'insertion donc on est aussi
chantier d'insertion avec 35 salariés en
insertion dans le dans le quotidien et
puis on travaille habituellement donc
vers les pays de l'est un petit peu
l'afrique mais c'était principalement
les pays de l'est avec vraiment le point
fort au moment de la guerre en bosnie
c'est ce qui nous est mis en route et
depuis juin
1993 est parti un camion tous les deux
mois jusqu'à aujourd'hui donc
aujourd'hui on fait un peu plus
maintenant mais depuis on a eu cette
continuité là donc avec des pays dont on
ne parlait pas toujours aux infos mais
sur lesquels il y avait toujours des
populations très vulnérable et
voilà ce qui on a continué en fait
pendant toute cette période est donc là
aujourd'hui on en est où quelles sont
concrètement les objectifs de
l'association et ont proposé à des par
exemple des chantiers vous disiez
d'insertion aujourd'hui on utilise donc
on vend collecte en fait tout ce qu'il
ya dans une maison qui est encore
utilisable on est une ressourcerie aussi
donc c'est avant la déchetterie tout
objet qui est utilisable comment va le
remettre en circulation et donc on
collecte ensuite s'il ya du
reconditionnement du
nettoyage un petit peu de tout ça une
grosse partie va partir en humanitaire
et puis une autre partie est revendue
donc dans un magasin type un peu emmaüs
donc voilà qui permet d'acquérir en fait
des biens à moindre prix et le sait bien
acheté permettent de financer à 50% la
l'insertion et à 50% la partie
humanitaire et donc ça concerne combien
de bénévoles en fait l'association on a
plus d'une centaine de bénévoles qui
fonctionne on a 35 salariés en insertion
et 10 salariés permanents
quand même beaucoup de mobilisations et
on vous avez rencontré jeudi lors du
départ d'un camion de dons en direction
de la roumaine et si je ne dis pas de
bêtises pour aider la population
ukrainienne c'était le premier depuis le
début de la guerre il y en aura d'autres
alors c'était le premier et il y en aura
d'autres en effet d'un premier camion en
direction de la roumanie évidemment pour
venir en aide aux réfugiés qui passent
la frontière il se trouve que on
travaille aussi avec la roumanie depuis
maintenant depuis plus de 20 ans
et donc on peut s'appuyer aussi sur nos
correspondants là bas pour passer le
relais eux mêmes se mobilisent avec
beaucoup d'organismes sur place
que ce soit là où ils se trouvent ou
bien directement au niveau de la
frontière avec du matériel prêté main
forte à ce qui se passe sur place oui et
bien et du coup vous avez un partenariat
avec les associations locales en classe
et je le disais le début fin le premier
depuis le début de la guerre mais au
final ça fait longtemps que vous
travailler là dessus puisque vous êtes
en contact avec eux depuis 2009 et vous
avez envoyé à peu près 7 700 tonnes en
13 ans de matériel avec le départ d'un
camion toutes les trois semaines c'est
bien ça à peu près oui on est ça on est
sûr c'est on est sur c chiffre là donc
oui avec l'ukraine notamment anne depuis
2009 on était même depuis avant avec
l'europe de l'est mais l'ukraine depuis
2009 et oui on est sûr c'est sur ces
tonnages là et la lidc même d'augmenter
avec les événements malheureux qu'on
connaît d'augmenter le rythme avec
un envoi par semaine sachant que on a eu
un camion la semaine passée et là on a
un envoie donc un semi remorque complet
qui part ce jeudi et là qui va aller
jusqu à lviv qui va donc rentrer en
ukraine et là après nos correspondants
prennent le relais pour la distribution
a justement c'est ce que j'allais vous
demandez pour le cheminement sur place
finalement comme ça se passe c'est eux
dont qui vous vous leur donnez enfin
vous leur envoyez et eux ils distribuent
sur place en fait c'est ça oui c'est
vraiment même notre fonctionnement j'en
veux dire de manière générale on
fonctionne avec des partenaires locaux
qui connaissent leur population qui
connaissent leur boulot leur besoin ils
ont les réflexes du terrain c'est eux
les experts sur place nous on est expert
de cette chaîne d'acheminement depuis la
collecte d'ici jusqu'à jusqu'à la
distribution là bas jusque jusqu au
déchargement voilà ensuite ils prennent
le relais
justement on va parler de cette collecte
donc puisqu'il ya donc d'autres convois
qui vont qui vont partir vous récupérer
du matériel notamment de la nourriture
longue conservation des fournitures
médicales des produits d'hygiène et des
produits pour bébés de quel matériel
quel matériel est primordial finalement
puisqu'il y en a besoin de tous
forcément mais mais qu'est ce qui est
primordial aujourd'hui
en fait en fait c'est vrai tout ce que
vous avez dit on est en train de
vraiment recentrer les collectes verser
ces produits là parce que c'est pas les
produits principaux que l'on a
actuellement en fin d'avant le conflit
maintenant peut-être le maître
l'alimentaire longue conservation et de
plats préparés ou bien en tout cas à
produits de longue conservation les
produits pour les enfants nourriture
pour les bébés on nous demande aussi
beaucoup de fournitures médicales
s'il y avait une urgence la plus extrême
ce serait peut-être ces produits là
puisqu'il relève vraiment de la vie de
la mort 1 évidemment mais c'est vrai
qu'on nous on insiste énormément sur
tout ce qui est produits d'hygiène parce
que le quotidien doit continuer
notamment les des couches bébé comme
adultes les produits d'hygiène le savons
et ses protections en protection aux
féminines et c'est qu'ils sont aussi ce
canton les a passé ça cela devient un
problème très important très rapidement
et aussi également on peut donc on peut
retrouver la liste des besoins sur votre
site internet l'intégralité du matériel
que vous pouvez apporter et en plus de
ce matériel finalement vous avez ouvert
une cagnotte en ligne a déjà trente deux
mille euros qui ont été récoltés à quoi
va servir cet argent alors il ya déjà
toute une partie 19000 qui ont pu être
directement transmis à nos partenaires
sur place et et faire des achats en fait
de nourriture avant que les villes
soient fermés donc ça c'était vraiment
important même avant que les camions
arrivent de pouvoir on soutient par
exemple des orphelinats voilà qu'ils
puissent faire des réserves en fait en
tant que c'était possible donc ça
c'était vraiment important ensuite on a
des achats spécifiques
alors bien sûr des fois c'est plus
intéressant de venir amener un sac avec
des petites choses dedans fait de
l'alimentaire ou comme ça mais en fait
si on fait un don ce nous ça nous permet
d'acheter en palettes et on a des tarifs
bien plus intéressant d'acheter en
palettes de des couches ou de
l'alimentaire donc c'est aussi une aide
de pouvoir faire un don et puis après on
a du matériel un peu spécifique là comme
dans le prochain convoi
des groupes électrogènes notamment c'est
en prévision parce que évidemment on ne
sait pas si l'électricité qu'est-ce qui
va fonctionner quand et plus les villes
sont touchées - les réseaux sont fiables
et donc c'est là qu'il faut prendre le
relais bain pour la conservation des
aliments et autres pouvoir cuisiner
pouvoir vivre au quotidien et donc ce
type d'équipement aussi va être
primordiale est donc là on a certains de
ses équipements groupe électrogène qui
partent ce jeudi avec le camion et puis
on espère avec les suivants aussi et on
espère une grâce à ces dons qui ont été
qui ont été mis directement de quoi et
bien sûr le lien aussi de la cagnotte
est à retrouver sur votre site internet
qui qui s'est affiché sur l'écran
merci beaucoup jean-marc ses moulins de
directeur de l'association je le
rappelle à la gerbe et puis michael
païta vous êtes le responsable pôle
solidarité merci beaucoup d'avoir été
avec notre leader
[Musique]
et suite à la décision de fermer
l'espace aérien européen aux compagnies
aériennes russes et aux sanctions
imposées au pays de nombreux français
ont donc dû quitter moscou pour revenir
en france et c'est le cas notamment de
lola 22 ans elle est rentrée de moscou
vendredi dernier c'est elle et chez ses
parents aux essarts-le-roi à présent un
reportage de nicolas landry et bixente
maya santisteva je cours je suis à
l'aéroport de moscou
j'ai mon agent il faut antalya dans deux
heures et après j'aurai quatre heures
d'escale et je verrai ankara où se passe
la nuit
il est 5 heures et quart je suis allé au
port dans 40 jours qui
j'ai passé la nuit sur un canapé
pendant les 90 à peu près
j'ai mon avion à cette heure donc encore
un peu d'attentes après une nouvelle
escale à vienne lola pu atterrir en
france un retour à la maison aux essarts
le roi a vécu comme un soulagement par
ses parents on est bien rassuré quand
même là même si on n'a pas paniqué
complètement parce que c'était pas on
n'était pas dans le cas à l'époque du
crâne elle était à moscou même le
périple pour rentrer il ya trente deux
heures de voyage pour faire à moscou
paris
voilà avec la difficulté que vous n'êtes
pas dans l'union européenne donc bah il
faut pouvoir trouver une zone de wifi
pour communiquer pour lola son séjour de
trois semaines a été écourtée partie le
samedi 19 février à moscou cet étudiant
de suivait des cours intensifs de langue
russe mais rien n'est perdu et elle va
terminer son cursus ils ont basculé les
courants distanti elle donc
voilà on va les avoir sur eux et puis
donc j'ai encore une semaine et demie de
cours en année sabbatique lola envie de
poursuivre ses voyages elle pourrait
partir dans quelques semaines à tel aviv
en israël
et je vous le disais en titre emmanuel
macron saura dans les yvelines ce lundi
soir pour son premier déplacement de
campagne le chef d'état a été invité par
karl olive le maire de poissy et le
rendez vous était donné à 18h30 grégory
canal et vous êtes sur place on vous
retrouve bonsoir bonsoir je sais vous
êtes le rédacteur en chef adjoint de tv
78 ou va se dérouler cette réunion et
quel est le programme finalement or le
président candidat est attendue d'ici
quelques minutes dans le bâtiment qui se
trouve derrière moi c'est le centre de
diffusion artistique de la ville c'est
là encore il ya quelques semaines qui
était implanté le centre de vaccination
de la ville alors dans la forme ce que
l'on sait c'est que les échanges ou
ensembles et à ce qui s'est défait
pendant le grand débat national les
habitants présents pourront échanger
autour de sujets qui la choisiront
promet l'équipe de campagne environ 300
personnes seront présentes choisi par la
ville de poissy elles ont reçu un mail
d'invitation signer directement de karl
olive le maire de poissy ex les
républicains qui est très proche des
manuels macron il est à l'origine et des
premiers comités de soutien à
départementaux dans les yvelines
emmanuel macron qui était je vous le
rappelle revenus et qui était venu en
octobre ici dans cette ville il avait
chaussé les crampons pour un match
caritatif du variétés club de france
j'ajoute aussi que les électeurs en 2017
pour les présidentielles avaient
largement à poissy voté pour emmanuel
macron ce n'est donc pas une surprise de
le voir venir ici pour son premier
déplacement de campagne à un peu plus de
30 jours désormais de ce premier tour
d'élection présidentielle il est
finalement presque à domicile arrivée
prévue des manuels macro ici à poissy à
18h30 le président sortant qui sera de
nouveau dans les yvelines cette semaine
puisque il présidera un sommet européen
de la défense ce sera jeudi et vendredi
du côté du château de versailles et bien
c'est noté merci pour ces informations
vers gorille à canal et le rappelle vous
êtes rédacteur en chef adjoint de tv 78
ans remercie également patrick jacques
de dixmude avec fougue pour la technique
et dans le reste de l'actualité
transformer les voitures thermiques en
électrique c'est possible avec car watts
cette entreprise basée à coignard
utilisent des batteries de deuxième vie
pour électrifier les péniches des tapis
de bagages dans les arbres les aéroports
ou encore des véhicules de safari céline
chassiron de surplace regarder que faire
des batteries de voiture une fois
qu'elles sont obsolètes l'entreprise
yvelinoise car watts à la réponse à la
question avec ses douze employés elle
réutilise des batteries comme les
batteries des eaux et renault qui ne
sont plus utilisables elles peuvent
garder jusqu'à 70 % de leurs capacités
car oui répond à une demande à la fois
politique et environnemental de
transformer la société du nom et
énergies carbonées à une énergie
décarbonée la députée de la 10e
circonscription aurore bergé la
sous-préfète de rambouillet florence
gilbert se sont déplacés pour visiter
l'entreprise
l'occasion de mettre en avant ces
startups qui dynamise le territoire on
encourage beaucoup les français
aujourd'hui à aller vers l'électrique à
aller vers des modèles qui sont moins
polluants il faut leur en donner les
moyens mais ça pose aussi la question de
l'avenir évidemment des batteries qui
sont utilisés c'est important d'avoir
des start up déjà parce que ça montre le
dynamisme du territoire ça montre aussi
des personnes qui s'engagent et qu'ils
réfléchissent à comment mieux vivre
demain et puis bien sûr parce que tout
ça derrière ces créateurs d'emplois car
what a bénéficié du plan france relance
après avoir répondu à un appel à projet
autour de la décarbonation une
subvention de l'état à hauteur de 450
mille euros leur a été accordé un
financement qui permet de les soutenir
dans leurs projets cette entreprise a pu
bénéficier de france relance parce
qu'elle présentait un modèle qui était
un modèle nouveau innovants qui
répondent à des besoins de
transformation énergétique ça nous a
aidé à conserver
d'ingénieurs pour pouvoir déposer les
brevets c'est notre sauvegarde et puis
c'est de savoir français une économie
circulaire vertueuse dans plusieurs
domaines l'aéroportuaire les véhicules
de safari ou encore le fluvial des
marchés que l'entreprise entend bien
multiplier dans les années à venir
et puis côté sport la 80e édition du
paris-nice et lancer la course cycliste
est parti de mantes la ville ce dimanche
6 mars une première étape remportée par
le cycliste français christophe laporte
de jumbo visma la deuxième étape est
parti à d'auffargis c'était ce lundi 7
mars matin à 12h15 un circuit de 160 km
direction orléans on écoute le maire de
la commune au micro de michael et demi
d'euros et nicolas d'andré c'est
vraiment exceptionnel parce que toute la
population a joué le jeu et puis j'ai la
chance d'avoir une grosse équipe de
bénévoles qui nous ont beaucoup aidés
parce que ça nécessite quand même de
l'installation du mariage et autres et
donc c'est vraiment c'est vraiment un
bon moment de fête et dans le cadre de
la course au soleil d'anciens cyclistes
professionnels se sont rendus ce lundi
matin dans le collège les molières aux
essarts-le-roi pour discuter avec les
élèves le reportage de mathilde franck
où peut-on vivre du cyclisme que faut-il
manger le matin avant une course ont
encore avez vous beaucoup voyagé voici
une idée des questions posées aux
anciens cyclistes professionnels sandy
casar et thomas voeckler par les élèves
du collège les molières aux
essarts-le-roi dans la salle des jeunes
fans aux anges c'est super c'est
agréable ça m'a fait découvrir plein de
trucs en ce moment franchement c'est
génial je pensais pas les rencontrer un
jour parce que je les connais quand même
et ça fait plaisir c'était super j'ai
appris plein de choses et ils ont pu
répondre à cette question que j'avais un
plaisir partagé par les coureurs je
trouve ça très très très sympa parce que
pour yahoo il parlait du cyclisme notre
sport de paris nice
mais il a aussi parlé c'est une
corrélation avec la vie de tous les
jours c'est à dire que il y à
l'entraînement la persévérance les
difficultés parce que le vélo c'est ça
il ya des jours où on est bien on n'est
pas bien c'est exactement la vie et on a
des questions aussi des collégiens qui
sont un peu différent de d'habitude
c'est important c'est sympa parce que
c'est vrai qu'on est habitué aux
chrétiens aux questions du journaliste
et convient dans les collèges comme
chaque année
on dans les yvelines avec paris nice et
bien il ya des questions qui change
rafraîchissante bien préparé donc c'est
un grand plaisir et de venir répondre
aux jeunes une rencontre organisée par
le département des yvelines et amaury
sport organisation à l'occasion de paris
nice cette année la course du soleil
s'est élancé de mantes-la-ville une
fierté de plus pour sandy casar grand
mère habite et invente la ville la
mairesse et de mantes-la-ville en plus
pour moi c'était un petit clin d'oeil où
j'ai fait deuxième sur cette course là
en 2002 sa fait 20ans sa part de
mantes-la-ville bon voilà c'est départ
du et divine de mon département
d'origine pour moi c'est important la
80e édition de paris-nice s'achèvera le
13 mars prochain
et le paris nice c'est le thème de votre
magazine sportif présenté par mika lenny
d'euros ce sera à suivre à 18h30 et
c'est la fin de ce journal merci à tous
de nous avoir suivis vous pourrez suivre
la réunion des manuels macron avec à
grégory canal et patrie jacques de
dixmude qui seront en facebook live sur
tv 78 très bonne soirée à tous
[Musique]